et enfin asnières nos joueurs se met à
dos strophes venir ici la place 84 et
une femme qui ont accepté ce soir car
des mandarins et simone de beauvoir donc
à lima publie les lettres à ça en
tournée et un journal de guerre qu'on
évolue dans tout ça c'est bien
le trésor parce qu'on peut tous ses
carnets c'est d'être perdue à jamais
voilà que o'meara qu'on les a retrouvés
donc c'est lui le beau journal de guerre
de pouvoir
c'est étonnant que la tenue le jour de
la méditation générale juste en janvier
41 et les lettres que cela ne revoit pas
décrit pas ça qui était qui était
prisonnier donc mais aussi d'autres
lettres puisque les 2130 1963 est
constituée quand même très intéressante
la extrêmement patient explique la
connaissance que vous avez vous pour
voir la même entreprise edel a changé
après l'électricité
c'est à dire qu elle a toujours dit pas
du tout en vert du départ à la face
cachée elle a toujours décalé ça n'avait
jamais d'été pendant la guerre familier
de la guerre des intellectuels engagés
des petits petits bourgeois
à marcher et qui se soucie surtout donc
d'une morale assez restaurative
stoïcienne c'est-à-dire qu'ils pensaient
être même libre assumer leur destin
royal a difference pour la télé
magnifique
donc elle a dit oui évidemment c'est
très différent pour un lecteur de
d'entendre le sentiment de pouvoir tenir
gp sectaire comme il a dit écrit et je
ne comprenais pas je ne prenais pas je
juge seul plutôt que vous prenez de lire
dans le journal par exemple de
stagiaires d'accréditation qu'elle avait
quels sont les déchets de l'humanité
évidemment c'est pas quelque chose et
que le colis dans le journal dans les
lettres que l'uniforme des saints
pareillement journal et les lettres dans
la vie vraiment dans la vie et avec tout
ce qui vient de coller au présent et à
distance
ces derniers avaient mis son passage
très surpris et vous êtes peut-être
chose
mais c'est de pouvoir la pensée ça elle
a écrit ça et mes parts qui n'a jamais
rien écrit dans son journal qu'il ne
puisse être un téléphone et plus du tout
paris se sont enfin parce que c'est
parce que sa fille adoptive y est les
premiers les manuscrits à tout ça dans
un placard chez lg a cédé 1
je souhaiterais par dix voix et c'est
une femme dont lorie ce qui veut dire
que je pense et moi ses lettres je ferai
ça coûte et nous dit mais pourquoi parce
qu'on puisse lui dire et ce depuis
entités i laquelle je suis certain pas
ça du tout sur le trio propriétaire
entre la petite vitrine le petit jeu
différent
normal tout ce que je fis je vais pour
vous le rapportez daf à l'enrichissement
de notre propre vie
par ce biais maintenir la communication
contre extraordinaire parce qu'il est
privilégiée parce qu'il n'est pas là
parce qu'il est parce qu il est
prisonnier il est moins précis
je ne dis pas que les lettres quelques
mois de mai dans ce département c'est
une grâce que je me dis à personne
elle a toujours dit la plus jamais et sa
dernière ne fait pas maintenant c'est
déjà bien beau qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
vous formule comment comment l'appel tel
est l'appel du petit mon cher petit ont
touché amour tout cher que tout est trop
tous chers petits
ma chère petite amie il se sert toujours
petit être mon cher amour
parce que c'est comme ces statistiques
elle est tout pour ça qu'elle est
évidemment peut-être en plaçant circuits
dits de livres ce qu'il fait
l'écuyer qui doit être la seule union
elle lui répond je pense qu'elle a
touchée par correspondance et c'est vrai
que ça donne une image ce pouvoir qui
n'est pas saine le comité habitude je
vais pas trouver de décret à moi je
trouvais une femme amoureuse jeunes en
effet qui défend son côté passionné
qu'un point un langage de dépasser
policiers mais qui décrit toute son
intensité est tué
ne va pas de travers les plastiques elle
de perverse et de méchants avec ses amis
et tout ça du parti de la vérité du
personnage
alors ce n'est pas l'image lequel on
était habitué par pas parvenus tant this
par la maîtresse femme qui dominent tous
tirent des leçons qui était notre rituel
qui réussit bien plus acide et qui en
son église comme ses détracteurs
alors tout ce monde était un peu déçu
tout l'érection de la sélection qui les
a gâtés de la presse qui ne met pas
assez de bien de ce compact des mandats
je me suis posé des question de tester
les réactions de la présentation des
modèles langage de corps de garde et
génération la duchesse de bouvard un
certain courage à m g regardant de
l'enquêté m des carnets sauta sur
l'atténuation carnet terre qui va venir
parce qu'on se laisse emporter par la
cimade et ciani c'est que ça nous
verrons exactement de sartomer je
laisserais peut-être même dès la
personne à part les quelques acquis
quatre nations arrivées
vous saviez que si l'un de vous voir
aussi l etat hélas il semble t-il pas
tellement de conviction
harry c'est mieux que dans les mémoires
les missionnaires dans ces lettres
étaient l'image du temps c'est ça qui
est passionnant vient juste toutes les
routes qui a incarné par ailleurs nous
viendrons mémoire donc ce qui est
passionnant on se trouve la vérité le
car est parti
bien sûr les relations des endroits
est ce que recherche de tous et en fait
d'être l'initiative et au pouvoir était
la communauté serait il ya que ça qui
risque était lectrice elle a élevé la ce
moment là maman jacques laurent boss qui
lui même est là n'ont rien fait
parce que dans un concours qui jour je
méritais deux cas la somme aux pékinois
ans on le suppose formation vitry
batterie l'amicale et la salariée le
navire voici une correspondance
je ne suis pas sorti de son vivant et
présente un entraîneur qu'il faut bien
le dire une famille il ya beaucoup de
choses des choses qui nous paraissent
est passé de 5 millions notre part il
faut dire si nous allons les aider nous
donnerait certainement un secteur exposé
aux spécialités pris 0 d'une future ses
descriptions de rebâtir ses descriptions
des pays sont reina d'une platitude au
total ensuite elle incarnait tout à fait
ce que j'appellerai ministre autorisent
idéologie dans la mesure où elles
apprenaient les dix l'égalitarisme entre
les l émancipation des femmes et
portrait des hommes et des femmes
il ne sommes pas des femmes et nous qui
ne sommes pas comme ça son départ est
particulièrement du livre la recette
family & prom et l'égalitarisme le
vision aristocratique et méprisante les
grands principes mais j'ajoute que j'ai
impressionné l'ap avoir fait la lecture
karine jusqu'au bout j'ai été
impressionné par l'as l'amour l'amour
qu'elle porte à ses qualités dynamiques
et or toutes ces déclarations d'amour
chauffe à 400 mètres sans doute
concentrés dans la seine et le lecteur à
supporter c'est c'est eh vit au jour le
jour minuté par minute un homme comme
lui j'entends prononcer des mots comme
comme vous dit que ce qu'elle a mangé
alors la déclaration d'amour et année et
demie c'est l'histoire d'amour
n'envoyez jamais supporté comptera dix
points à venir voir comment ça c'est à
dire que la première chose c'est que on
est fait
c'était très lettres qui sont toutes
écrites à peu près passant de revoir un
peu plus tentants laquelle je sais juste
toute vérité est devenu il faut jamais
les coupes avant la mort de la
littérature mais il est évident qu'on
écrit à quelqu'un quand on écrit dans
n'a jamais cherché à faire de la
littérature et m'a dit non je cherche
les magistrats se dire je crois que même
rien que par exemple
maintenant je suis vraiment c'est une
édition des lettres
le parquet a requis son émission
passionnante mais tout savoir sur le
projet nous attendons à ce que ces gens
là soient des icônes et idoles ils
n'étaient pas ils ont peut-être
contribué à ce que cette image mais ils
ont leurs travers et encore